according to Grimace Legend no one in
the entire world knows the current
whereabouts of Grimace Island the Grimes
lived in harmony dressing up in tribal
clothing and living in these giant hives
imagine you're an Explorer in the 1800s
after sailing the Seas By Moonlight you
come across an island and seek shelter
and you notice these great big caves
sitting on the hill you go inside but
then you hear breathing you start to see
the whites of eyes blinking all around
and that's when you realize you're
standing in a huddle of grimaces it's
not such a far-fetched story one day A
Tribe of humans appeared on the island
in search of treasure and made off with
much of it but the most valuable of the
treasure was hidden away underground to
protect what they had the gorons I mean
the grimaces performed a sacred dance
causing the islands to break away from
its Moorings and float away into
uncharted waters this is probably a good
time for me to emphasize just how
massive these creatures are at the time
of the legend of Grimace Island in 2001
Grimace is stated to be a crushing 900
lb